the bees show the TV show going to
reunite with some amazing brothers doing
some wonderful work haven't seen one and
Wow almost over a decade and the other
one a long time let's go check out the
brothers I think this was a decade how
long has it been since we've seen each
other but it oh yeah yeah and then John
half a decade brothers reunite how do
you guys feel now that it's it's
Christmas you guys both being former
Christians correct yeah and now with
family and everything and how do you
guys for other people who are they
accepted Islam and now the how this
holiday comes around Christmas and how
do you guys deal with it and what advice
do you give for others our community was
talking about this this morning man hmm
my community romain Committee was really
an on fire because it is this morning
and they're asking and so on and they're
sending different videos
look when I believe that if you're a
good son or a good daughter throughout
the year and you reach out to your
parents in to your family and you you
know contribute to your family and you
you're there for them you love them you
protect them you serve them you you show
them good character man that Islam
actually you know asked us to do and I
think your absence for one day of the
year is not going to be filled with if
you excuse yourself and they understand
the respect your your opinion what
you're doing
alarm I don't think it's gonna it's
gonna make a huge difference but if
you've never showed up the whole year
and all of a sudden you find it you know
this is the only opportunity you know
it's not easy subhanAllah I mean my
family the they're not really Christian
anymore they don't really have a
religion but they celebrate Christmas
it's heavily heavily you know they're
preparing all year for this day so it's
not easy when you know every year
they're asking me you know come for
Christmas and it's not easy and I make a
point of not going on Christmas Day you
know just you know because we have to
keep to our principles you know and you
know we've got so many other days in the
year and we can buy gifts I could just
talk my mother a gift it's not Christmas
but I just buy a gifts every time I see
you you know and but they know my stance
on Chris I'm not shy I'm not shy because
you know once you start doing the you
know practicing Christmas and think you
know because that's everything what's
the issue is it that they were not there
or not bringing gifts so we're not being
nice or is it just that you're not
participating in a celebration of them
yeah they want you to just do what they
what they do now what's the big deals
family people like you see even some
Muslims putting on the hats this is
Merry Christmas and we're just having a
good time well why you guys trying to
ruin the party as John said it's an
issue of principle right
this cam this kind of argument can be
used for everything that people's tend
to in their lives you know I mean if you
if you hold on to something and if you
look at the origins of Christian of
Christmas and what it stands for and so
on you know the Muslim has to has to has
to have a limit the most amassed have a
limit you know that I believe that the
more we try to use these you know
fallacious arguments you know it's so
sad I mean every year you seen more and
more just practicing Christmas exactly
it's just I think it's how much this is
this is you know this is against our
fundamental principles of Islam I mean
so what is it when you have pretty much
the core is that you're saying that the
Almighty did the Creator that he came
down committed suicide when you could
get down to it and then he he pretty
much died so there's a whole theology
and this is what we're staying away from
this is correct
I mean you we did something before about
even I remember a few years ago yeah
can't shake ah go but you guys have a
deeper insight because you guys bought
again we're your families are Christian
from a Christian background would you
want to say gibreel well I think we have
to make a distinction between as John
said you know his parents they're like
they're not really Christian like
they're probably not really celebrating
the theology yeah they're just okay it
is just the whole
you know celebration but people might
say well what is why is it harmful
because you know it's not a Christian
it's not a Christian celebration anymore
but it has its roots in the Christian
celebration and has its roots in be no
celebration yeah and and look at look
what all this is about about those who
say II so is this another one you know
it's such a grave sin to accuse and
claim that Allah has a son you know
because actually that the skies would
break apart
just because of saying that so again
it's not me my opinion or your opinion
in this opinion it's just that I lost my
does establish certain boundaries yeah
and that doesn't mean that we have to be
pricks about it and that we have to be
evil to people and fight and listener
but politely say this is my stand man
you know just like everything people
political stances people have cultural
stances people have sports and teams and
things that they like right if they're
so passionate about it right and if
someone is gonna go over the line that
they've established in their life be
culturally be it you know there's the
principles in life work or so on and
they're not gonna have it right but when
it comes to Islam that we ourselves
acknowledge saying that this is our life
and this is what we believe in we start
locks you know I found you know people
of other religions and no religions
don't have the same issues like it is
when someone becomes a Christian or Sikh
Buddhist or atheist the family um seemed
to be more acceptance for some reason
when it comes to Islam you know it
reminds me of the Iowa almost says you
know
you know they will not be happy with you
until you leave your religion it's like
you don't see this kind of bullying it's
kind of like what bullying it's not you
that they don't happy with it's Allah
and His Messenger what about the what
about people don't think like we don't
when somebody comes around right this is
the the holiday where we commemorate
Abraham his willingness to sacrifice for
God his son right but we don't expect
people to go ahead and start you know
coming to eat and celebrating with us or
or when someone does let's say the the
Hindu religion come to the Hindus who
have their their practices nobody is
expecting the Christians to go and do
the Hindu 81.0 yeah let's if we break it
down you'll find that the in celebration
is something that does not disagree with
Christian that's another good point it
doesn't like any Christian I will look
into it to eat the Muslim celebration
they'd actually connect more with that
that's right and and that's the point
it's an issue of principle you know
sometimes what they do like say say your
friend or your non-muslim friend or
family maybe they join you for eat and
then they try and use that against you
that's right to bribe you to come to
blackmail you to come to Christmas the
same we came to your celebrations for
celebration this doesn't work like that
like you don't have to come to our
celebration you're welcome if I serve
water okay or juice mango juice we both
like it we both agree with it right it's
good right but if after I've served you
mango juice if you offer me a cup of
wine it's not the same effect is it you
know what I mean so I'm not trying to
insult anyone and that's not I don't
think this is the point of of any of the
Muslims rejecting the practices of
Christmas or Easter or other things
that's not the point that we're not
trying to say that we're just you know
these these very extreme people who are
not we don't embrace anyone they don't
agree with everyone it's their way or
the highway we're not saying that that's
what we rationalizing
so why was he going so fast but who are
watering these things now if the I know
people are saying it's not that you know
times they're different times have
changed times are problematic now it's
not the same but we find that the Sahab
of the process Ellen who were all pretty
much new Muslims all of them they were
facing family problems you can't say can
use the argument that back in the days
it was different and today we're facing
new challenges yes we have a lot any
challenges but the theology of some of
the Christian practices or some of the
cultural practices you could find a lot
of parallels between what happened at
the time of the process eleven Sahaba
and the new Muslims them and what's
happening today but you never find the
process or Selim asking the people that
okay this is not you know don't worry
just take it easy let's do it and you
find in the in the visit of the
Christians of Niger on to the process
emmerich when there was that discussion
the process M was not rude to them the
process M didn't - Gary were still kind
they asked him kindly to go and remove
the whole you know shebang that they
were rare you know because it was it was
not fitting it was not befitting they
were wearing a lot of sari idols you
know yeah and he politely asked him if
you want to talk to me and they had a
long discussion was like I think the
delegation stayed there for like seven
days yeah yeah those who's a polite
discussion and a good discussion and
allowed to stay in the Masjid exactly
but wasn't them one thing if you're here
then just respect you know like because
again going to the principal crescentin
did Jesus actually do that I mean just
make but just oversimplifying the Jesus
actually do that the Jesus actually
where these idols do Jesus actually
practice Christmas that Jesus actually
put up a Christmas tree and you find it
you have a lot of Christians who are
actually against many of these pagan
rituals because you come down it's
incorporated brought in for many pagan
religions like the Christmas tree right
it actually tells you in the light tells
you not to put up tree doesn't it and
we're actually following the Bible more
aren't we if you think about it hasn't
it gotten like commercialized where you
go is just become one big party and
people drinking and you know promiscuity
and all these other commercialized big
business do you see like that definitely
I think people need to understand that
bottom line is that we're not can see
there or you know trying to be
disrespectful or we're just trying to
rationalize things to people be like
this is why we're not doing it and this
is why you shouldn't do it either you
know does it pretty much it comes down
to if you want to do what God wants you
to do if you want to you want to obey
your Creator the one God this is why
we're doing it we're staying away from
this to please the Creator because this
is something that when you look deep
into it
you see that the association of partners
of God you know many of these pagan
rituals and this is not disrespecting
anybody or anybody's what is it but
standing on principles out of love and
fear for God and anybody who does the
same thing they're gonna fall in line
with that what do you guys think so this
is a few Muslims having a discussion
about Christmas what are their final
closing advice do you give for those
really that now this time of the year
that can take from two former come a
form of some former people who are also
kind of doing the same thing Christians
and now they're ones who submitted to
the will of the creator Muslim what do
you guys got to say signs pocket and
this is out of the love this is this is
out of the respect now putting anybody
or facing yeah because there's a lot of
bullying people trying to force things
on other people and we're just backing
out just because hey man this is this is
something that we're standing out some
principles that we really what were you
gonna say to real I was talking to
someone this morning and they're saying
like you know you guys kind of don't
really understand because you're living
in with some countries and I said no
I've been moving around the whole world
and experiencing different cultures and
living in different cultures it's not
about that we don't we do understand and
we know that it's not an easy thing it's
definitely not an easy thing so Oren
we're not gonna pretend because I know
where I've been and I'll be very honest
have I gone to certain Christmas dinners
when I was a new Messiah
ya know when I when I when I first came
to Islam I was living in my parents
house and I didn't they did
even though I was a Muslim so Christmas
Day came you just have to shut the door
you just have to go through the fear of
the day you know what can you do you
know for me the lesser of the two evils
was to not let them find out that I was
Muslim
you know and otherwise it would have
been made homeless at the time he wasn't
until hamdulillah I managed to you know
they found out I was a Muslim I managed
to get my own place
then I'm in charge you know I can I can
say look I don't celebrate Christmas and
I'm happy to come any other any other
time you have to stick to your
principles you know because if you if
you start going down the the path you
know of letting your your belief go then
today is Christmas and tomorrow is
something else and this is what you see
with the Muslims you know solely slowly
one two three
you kind of become just you know you're
more concerned about pleasing the people
become what's called a sycophant right
and and instead of pleasing the one who
created you so some nice little
discussion hopefully you guys can
benefit from and take from this from
people who also been there done that
we've seen also me and Eddie we have
some videos yes I'm a few years ago for
Christmas one of those call they can
look it up I think one was his sons are
white yeah you got that's a whole
different discussion yeah Jesus his name
to really just did that Jesus's name we
yeah and I've got some videos on the
slum Weis channel as well you know
advice just how to get through it with
the family so uh check them on show okay
guys we'll see more of you saw Michael
and please